en esquí
el profesor sobre el se volvió de nuevo
el jefe de servicio dinámico que era
antes de la enfermedad
nos habíamos reunido hace más de un año
en su unidad de tratamiento del dolor
transformada entonces en una unidad como
estaba hospitalizado en su propio
servicio sus pensaba la cantidad de
muertos que hay aquí a la velocidad
porque ahora salvamos a la gente y no
solamente le sube hay patologías que
aparecerán otra vez
después de su entrevista fui transferido
a la unidad de reanimación de cuidados
intensivos en el hospital henri mondor
debido a mi degradación respiratoria de
el trabajo de las unidades médicas como
la del profesor sobre él era menos
mediatizado que el de los servicios de
reanimación o trabajo sin embargo
primordial en el marco de la atención a
los pacientes hobbits y el trabajo de
los equipos médicos era apreciar bien a
los pacientes bien apreciados por su
evolución y crear una reacción muy
rápida y muy eficaz que permita hacer
pasar las etapas sin irse a reanimación
la dedicación total de los médicos
durante la pandemia tuvo consecuencias y
desafortunadamente hubo mucha licencia
por enfermedad
diría que la crisis del cobi precipitó
su partida
para mí mis colegas que se quedaron era
una experiencia humana
estábamos en una situación que nos
recordó nuestro papel principal de
médicos y pando en metz 11 de tratar de
salvar vidas
con el flujo de la pandemia el servicio
retomó su actividad de tratamiento del
dolor con pacientes un poco abandonados
durante las olas sucesivas de kobe